alemania endurece su postura sobre un
controvertido gasoducto entre rusia en
europa después de semanas de vacilación
la ministra de relaciones exteriores de
alemania confirmó que sistema de ucrania
el oleoducto north stream 2 estaría en
riesgo en el caso de una nueva agresión
hay una variedad de respuestas
disponibles incluido norte stream 2 si
queremos diálogo en todo momento pero en
vista de la situación actual también
necesitamos dureza si el producto ha
causado divisiones desde que se anunció
en 2015 construido a lo largo del fondo
del mar báltico hasta alemania evita la
ruta tradicional a través de ucrania y
corre paralelo al nord stream 1
duplicando la dependencia energética de
la unión europea de rusia north stream 2
finalizado el pasado septiembre está
detenido hasta que los reguladores
alemanes abran las válvulas cancelar el
proyecto de 9500 millones de euros
supondría un duro golpe financiero para
rusia
si bien es posible poner a europa bajo
presión eventualmente el continente
recurrirá al gas licuado de otros países
eso significa que los rusos perderán su
mercado
para cortar los suministros vitales de
gas en pleno invierno también podría
causar grandes problemas económicos y
sociales para las naciones de la unión
europea el gobierno de eeuu dice que
está trabajando en un plan de
contingencia acercarse a qatar y otros
grandes productores de energía para
aumentar el gas a europa en caso de que
se corte el suministro ruso sin embargo
este tipo de acuerdos generalmente se
realizan a través de contratos a largo
plazo y los precios de la energía ya
están disparados en toda europa con
rusia supuestamente restringiendo los
suministros de gas existentes para
presionar a occidente